[Musique]
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver dans parlement hebdo
l'essentiel de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire de la semaine avec mickey
rourke katia bonjour jean christophe
lagarde
bonjour vous êtes notre invité cette
semaine président du diy députés les
constructive de seine-saint-denis de
sujets à la une on va évidemment les
détails et la bataille du budget qui bat
son plein à l'assemblée suppression du
sf flat tax
l'opposition dénonce un budget pour les
riches et la sécurité le président de la
république à dévoiler ses pistes et
notamment la création de la police de
sécurité du quotidien mais d'abord
l'épreuve de feu dans l'hémicycle
l'examen du budget 2010 8
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
suppression de l' isf sous sa forme
actuelle création d'une flaque taxe
prélèvement unique sur le capital ces
mesures emblématiques anime les débats
dans l'hémicycle
stéphanie des pierres les députés ont
adopté le prélèvement forfaitaire unique
cette taxe à 30 % sur les revenus du
capital
objectif du gouvernement orienter
l'épargné vers l'investissement
mais la gauche en doute la question se
pose de savoir si cet argent va pouvoir
entrer dans l'économie réelle
la réponse est connue c'est non pour
l'arrivée les socialistes dénoncent un
chèque en blanc et s'inquiète d'une
fuite des capitaux à l'étranger
en réalité vous pouvez passer votre
argent n'importe où y compris un fonds
de placement étrangers
vous pourrez choisir general electric
plutôt qu alstom siemens plutôt
qu'alstom vous prêt choisir ce que vous
voudrez et vous n'aurez absolument
aucune condition pour bénéficier de ce
nouveau taux de la flat tax pour rendre
la taxe efficace bruno le maire misé sur
le bon sens des français
qu'est ce qui garantit que cette épargne
ira vers les entreprises vers
l'investissement en actions mais une
chose toute simple le bon sens des
français qui sont déjà qu'ils ont déjà
choisi de placer 40% de leur épargne
dans les entreprises dans les actions
dans les produits entrepreneuriaux parce
qu'ils ont parfaitement compris que sur
le long terme la rentabilité de ce
placement est supérieur à le
rentabiliser des placements immobiliers
le bon sens des français vaut tous vos
raisonnements monsieur mélenchon les
députés ont aussi longuement débattu du
plan épargne logement ensemble la
nouvelle gauche et est républicain
demande l'exonération pour les pl avec
la flat tax nous allons arriver à ce
paradoxe que nous allons faire un cadeau
d'un milliard neuf à ceux qui ont les
plus grandes fortunes et que nous
refusons que vous refusez 800 millions
d'euros pour continuer à exonérer des
plans épargne logement qui jusqu'ici
étaient exonérés fin de non-recevoir de
bruno le maire qui en profite pour
attaquer ses anciens collègues de droite
nous aimer l'économie et vous décrivez
vous même comme libéral à libéral ne
devrait pas apprécié qu'on dépense de
l'argent public pour un produit qui ne
répond plus à l'intérêt général
au total la nouvelle flat tax coûtera 1
25 milliard d'euros au budget de l'état
jean christophe lagarde longtemps les
critiques de certains cadeaux faits aux
investisseurs vous vous pensez quoi
est ce que le gouvernement ne prend pas
un risque en estimant que l'argent qui
ne sera plus imposée ou épargner en
pensant qu'il sera automatiquement
reversés à l'économie ce que vous pensez
que c'est un pari risqué pour réussir au
préalable à ce que je peux vous faire de
réflexion la première c'est que on a une
culture en france du débat budgétaire
qui était assez curieuse dans votre
présentation parler de bataille
budgétaire est ce que vous savez que
dans des pays normaux démocratique
intelligent il ya même des commissions
budgétaires majorité-opposition discute
et la majorité écoute parfois corrige et
là on est dans le sentiment de la
bataille d'ailleurs vos extrêmement pur
cardiaque et rezaï politiques dont aucun
n'est acquis raison et l'autre qui est
hors pardon je ne crois pas moins
qu'aucun gouvernement que j'ai vu depuis
quinze ans je suis parlementaire est
toujours raison et tort est toujours
tort et quand on nous parle de nouveaux
comportements politiques de nouveau
monde je pense qu'il faudrait que tout
le monde soit dans cet état d'esprit en
tout cas c'est le cas du groupe que nous
avons constitué c'est de dire il ya et
c'est le deuxième point il ya des
réformes
c'est la réponse à votre question il ya
des réformes ça nous change de françois
hollande et dans ses réformes il ya du
bon et du moins bon
est-ce que la flat tax est une bonne
chose oui oui et elle est encore
supérieure à ce qui se trouve dans les
autres pays européens
et pour éviter que l'argent sert le
capital on frôlerait que que enfin dans
cette une taxe égale pour tout le monde
ment ça s'appelle au capital il est
dommage d'ailleurs qui ne l'appliquent
pas également à l'immobilier qu'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui les gens qui
ont de l'argent s'ils placent leur
argent en france ils payent beaucoup
plus d'impôts que s'il le place ailleurs
par exemple dans l'union européenne
est-ce que du coup l'argent en question
qui va en allemagne créé des emplois en
france évidemment non est-ce que cet
argent doit venir en france et pour près
d emploi c'est utile je partage cette
direction politique
deuxième exemple la suppression de l'
isf pour en fait le remplacer par
l'impôt sur la fortune de l'héritière je
pense à chaque match je pense que ça
c'est une erreur
c'est une erreur je vais vous dire
pourquoi d'abord parce qu'aujourd'hui
lit et s'est fait un impôt absurde ça
n'existe plus en europe n'est qu'en
france qu'on fait ce genre de choses
ce qui est un impôt absurde qu'il
faudrait purement et simplement
supprimées alors en france on se dit si
on supprime l'impôt sur la fortune c'est
injuste parce qu on exonère les riches
non c'est faux si j'ai signé la pétition
qui demande transparence dans un instant
mais justement je veux de la
transparence et les grandes fortunes et
immense fortune ne paye pas les s est
justement d ce qui est ce qu'ils payent
dsf sont ce que j'appellerais entre
guillemets les petits riches les
modestement riches c'est votre médecin
parce qu'il n'a pas le droit à la
retraite sécurité sociale qui constitue
un patrimoine immobilier
c'est votre charcutier votre boucher
votre masson qui fait ça parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de couverture pour la retraite
et donc cela pdsf cependant que les
grandes fortunes les grandes fortunes se
madame par exemple je ne paye a pâli s
est donc cet impôt est idiot et à un
impôt idiot et ben on invente un autre
impôt idiot tout aussi injuste elle
était inéquitable
je termine ma phrase juste là dessus
c'est est inéquitable et inefficace et
je pense qu'on est en train d'inventer
un autre impôt qui est inéquitable et
inédit et et inefficace il a qu'une
vertu cclin c'était 4 milliards et veut
c'est un milliard un milliard d'
absurdité plutôt que quatre mais c'est
toujours pas la bonne réforme pour ceux
qui savent pas évidemment il ya eu un
appel lancé par 120 parlementaires ses
fans à bagnols où le résume évidemment
vous pourrez développer juste après le
but de cette initiative est clairement
de coller encore et toujours à emmanuel
macron cette fameuse étiquette de
président des riches
parmi les signataires figurent de
nombreux socialistes on est sur cette
affaire de l'usf sur une une volonté
transparente de privilégier une certaine
partie de la socialité la start up
nation
les gagnants de la mondialisation et
puis les autres je veux pas reprendre
les formules à la mode les feignants
ceux qui partent en vacances
il demeure quand même dans cette affaire
une forme de mépris mais certains
sénateurs socialistes eux n'ont pas
signé pour une raison simple ils peuvent
en réalité déjà accéder à ces
informations via la commission des
finances
le groupe socialiste au sénat dispose
par le truchement de vincent eblé de la
présidence de cette commission et que de
par son statut il a la capacité d'avoir
l'ensemble de ces informations
en se rendant à bercy en effectuant un
contrôle sur pièces et sur place le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
bruno le maire dans une interview au
journal le monde aujourd'hui a répondu
par la négative à cette affaire il n'est
pas question de remettre en cause le
secret fiscal
nous allons rendre 400 millions d'euros
aux 1000 premiers contributeurs
soit quatre cent mille euros en moyenne
pour chacun de ses contributeurs vous
demandez donc la transparence comme
vivier vous disais qu'il y est c'est
fait une erreur en l'état est ce que
vous ferez ce budget écoutez je reviens
sur ma première réponse
moi j'aimerais que le budget ça soit
l'occasion d'une discussion sérieuse
solide et ouverte entre tout le monde je
comprends ne l'est pas aujourd'hui
évidemment je comprends j'y viens je
comprends que monsieur mélenchon soit là
pour faire soit pas sa propagande
d'ailleurs le slogan président des
riches et de la propagande dans ce
budget il ya à peu près huit français
sur dix nous c'est de la propagande mais
aujourd'hui c'est de la propagande
communiste avec la 6e journée pas obligé
de le chanter sur tous les tons et de le
croire dans ce budget il ya à peu près 8
français sur 10 qui vont gagner un peu
pouvoir d'achat est-ce qu'il ya 80% de
français qui sont riches
oui bien que c'est de la propagande et
moi je veux qu'on change la politique
pour que ça ne soit plus du reflex mais
de la réflexion lumière en français je
revois la langue bien non on va se je
reconnais que c'est pas habituel mais
vous croyez que les français ils nous
ont envoyé à l'assemblée nationale après
avoir élu emmanuel mercinier pourquoi
vous croyez
les français ils veulent qu'on fasse la
même chose qu'avant lorsque je peux
regretter c'est que le débat budgétaire
ne soit pas un lieu de construction plus
partagés tout simplement parce que c'est
la majorité qui ne fait pas la majorité
semble penser que dès que quelque chose
leur ai dit qui n'est pas conforme à ce
qu'ils souhaitent c'est une agression
non c'est une proposition c'est pour
éviter les erreurs c'est pour corriger
le tir et pour l'instant je trouve que
le réflexe de la majorité actuelle qui
prêchent souvent le nouveau monde
ressemble furieusement à l'ancien monde
et je le regrette
et tant pis on portera nous dès qu'on
porte des comportements politiques
différents parce que je le répète il ya
des bonnes choses dans ce budget et il
est plus sérieux et plus honnête que
celui que j'ai vu que ce que j'ai vu
depuis une quinzaine d'années on triche
pas sur la croissance
on essaye de faire des économies même si
c'est plus souvent dans la poche des
autres que dans la bouche de l'état etc
et en même temps puisque c'est la mode
en même temps il ya des erreurs dans ce
budget
par exemple on n'est pas encore sur le
plfss sur la csg par exemple sur l'impôt
sur la fortune immobilière et méritait
peut-être sur cette idée en 30 secondes
vous nous dites le nouveau monde
correspond finalement ce qu'on vivait
avant celles entièrement donnez nous un
exemple
et pourquoi quel élève qui les hagist
finalement quand même quelle est la
politique si on entend bien et c'est
bien ce que je vous dis c'est bien ce
que je regrette
ça a été beaucoup expliqué avant les
élections et depuis les élections
la capacité d écoute de construction de
majorités d'idées de la part de la
majorité actuelle n'existe pas ou
n'existe quasiment que marginalement
facialement je vous prends un exemple le
gouvernement est en train de commettre
beaucoup de bêtises de préparer beaucoup
de bêtises et de dire de gros mensonges
sur le logement et la réforme du
logement
il ya besoin d'une réforme du logement
ça a complètement dérapé
on dépense des milliards et des
milliards et en même temps on a une
crise du logement qui ne cessent pas il
commet des bêtises nous sommes sur tous
les bancs politique beaucoup à dire
attention là vous vous trompez il ya des
technocrates qui décide des choses qui
sont absurdes
le gouvernement est il capable d'écouter
c'est un défi nous on n'est pas après
tout je pourrais tirer dessus tous les
matins en disant c'est une cellule c'est
parce que je dis je dis ne faites pas
cette erreur parce que c'est les
français qui payent la facture d'accord
alors cette semaine jean christophe
lagarde les députés ont aussi examiné
vous l'évoquez à l'instant le budget de
la sécurité sociale en commission parmi
les mesures adoptées l'extension de la
vaccination obligatoire
cette mesure qui fait débat le fait que
l'obligation vaccinale sont intégrés au
préfet cesse nous contraint de limiter
les débats au strict minimum
or on constate une véritable défiance de
la part des français concernant la
vaccination et je trouve ça très
regrettable
nous avons également mieux évaluer les
raisons de la méfiance qui s'accroît
l'égard de la vaccination en la méthode
comme le calendrier qui ont été imposées
ne nous le permettent pas et dans un tel
contexte une telle mesure risque de
renforcer la défiance des français
envers les vaccins 11 vaccins
obligatoires est ce que c'est une mesure
vraiment nécessaire si vous êtes
d'accord avec ça je pense je trouve que
nous avons là encore des débats
consternant en france moi j'ai présidé
la commission d' enquête sur la grippe a
à l'époque mais j'ai découvert beaucoup
de choses sur la vaccination sur les
raisons de l'échec de cette campagne de
vaccination mais surtout sur le doute
que des français ont sur la vaccination
pourquoi aujourd'hui on a quasiment plus
de tuberculose dans notre pays parce
qu'on a rendu la tuer de la vaccination
obligatoire sur plusieurs générations la
tuberculose était un fléau elle a
disparu
est ce que vous croyez que le risque
vaccinale qui existe qui est
infinitésimal mais qui existe il est
supérieur au reste attrapé la
tuberculose
voilà le raisonnement il est finalement
simple donc il faut nier nier qu'il peut
exister à la marge
un risque vaccinale mais c'est le même
que quand vous prenez un cachet
d'aspirine madame afin de
je vais pas donner de mars à tomber
n'importe quels médicaments que vous
prenez peut à un moment donné vous
rendre malade mais vous le prenez pas ce
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de chance qui
vous soigne et dans le cas du vaccin
même de l'alliance sur ce sujet bowie
méfiance qu'elle savait ça veut dire que
ça veut dire que dans la société ultra
médiatisé et des réseaux sociaux dans
laquelle nous sommes raconte tout et
n'importe quoi
on fait croire à des gens que le risque
du vaccin est supérieur au risque de la
maladie
or l'état à la responsabilité de
conduire des mesures de santé publique
et je vous disais que la tuberculose
avaient disparu elle a quasiment disparu
et en plus exactement elle a disparu
maintenant l art est paru dans mon
département de la seine saint denis a à
nouveau des cas de tuberculose
il ya quelques années on a arrêté de
rendre la vaccination obligatoire c'est
intelligent bon rester sur ce point et
on va avancer sur un autre sujet si vous
voulez bien jean christophe lagarde
avec une question qui était au coeur de
l'actualité cette semaine c'est le sujet
du terrorisme et de la sécurité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors cette semaine au sénat la loi
antiterroriste a été définitivement
adoptée après donc dernier vote du sénat
elle prendra le relais donc de l'état
d'urgence à partir du 1er novembre
et dans l'autre temps et bien emmanuel
macron dit qu'elle a dévoilée justement
lui aussi sa stratégie en matière de
sécurité et de lutte antiterroriste avec
une doctrine est un nouvel outil
précision de stéphanie des pierres
emmanuel macron lance la police de
sécurité du quotidien ps qu en abrégé
elle a changé de nom mais pour le moment
elle ressemble étrangement à la police
de proximité lancées par lionel jospin
et supprimée par nicolas sarkozy et
bagnols macro explique que non c'est
différent pour en définir les contours
il reprend en partie les mots de nicolas
sarkozy la sécurité du quotidien c'est
lutter contre tout ce qui fait naître
chez nos concitoyens les sentiments
d'insécurité qui leur donnent l'image de
l'impuissance publique répondre à ses
attentes ce n'est pas remettre en place
une police de proximité avec des postes
de police statique dans les quartiers ce
n'est pas comme on a parfois dénoncé
aller jouer au football avec les jeunes
c'est au contraire exercer votre métier
de policier qui représente une autorité
qui conforte et qui rassure mais qui
rappelle aussi les règles de vie en
société chaque fois que c'est nécessaire
dès lundi la ministre de l'intérieur
lancera une large concertation avec les
élus les syndicats de police et tous les
acteurs de la sécurité publique et
privée pour le député olivier falorni la
police de sécurité au quotidien peut
être utile je crois qu'on a besoin
effectivement d'une police qui soit
en lien avec les citoyens qui
comprennent la vie des gens tout en
sanctionnant les manquements à la loi et
qui puisse faire remonter un certain
nombre de renseignements que les
services de renseignement qui ont été
très centralisé n'ont plus vraiment dans
un communiqué les républicains dénoncent
tout un dispositif qui a démontré son
inefficacité et qui fleure bon les
années jospin mais tous les députés de
droite ne sont pas contre cette nouvelle
police julien dive s'inquiètent
cependant d'une baisse des effectifs
dans les commissariats de province
moi ce que je crains c'est que on retire
simplement le patch du policier national
aujourd'hui qui est engagée sur
d'intervention qui est engagée sur la
police judiciaire et qu'on y mette le
patch psq police de sécurité du
quotidien auquel cas on se retrouve à
déshabiller pierre pour habiller paul
et on n'a pas de moyens complémentaires
supplémentaires emmanuel macron a promis
des moyens supplémentaires
les premières expérimentations
commenceront début 2018 dans une
quinzaine de sites
est-ce que vous avez compris vous jean
christophe lagarde à quoi peut servir
cette nouvelle police vu qu'il existe
déjà une police municipale et est ce que
c'est le retour des îlotiers c'est quoi
de quoi s'agit-il
on a un problème en france avec la
promenade la police et l'efficacité
d'ailleurs du couple police justice le
premier des problèmes c'est que par la
culture de la police d'intervention par
la dénonciation de nicolas sarkozy de
duke policiers qui joue au football on a
complètement changé de culture policier
n'a pas joué au football
sauf qu'il n'a pas non plus à ne plus
rencontrer la population une police
efficace et une police qui a obtient des
renseignements et ça c'est parce qu'il
croise tous les jours des gens dans un
quartier c'est parce que tous les jours
il discute avec un accent c'est la
police d'un forme mais vous ne pouvez
pas faire une enquête contre un
cambriolage un sac à un vol de sac à
main ou et si vous n'avez pas de
l'information la police elle peut pas
seul savoir tout ce qui se passe elle a
besoin des français donc de leur
confiance donc de les connaître donc de
les rencontrer en gare construite et
donc les de ce qu'il fait a expliqué oui
mais je crois que ce n'est pas la seule
chose remettre la police en lien avec la
population pour qu'elle gagne leur
confiance et que du coup elle et de
l'information et qu'elle soit plus
efficace dans ses investigations et pour
arrêter
deuxième chose quand même c'est que ça
sert à rien d'arrêté les gens si la
justice n'a pas les moyens de les
traiter
donc de traiter les coupables ça fait
partie des leaders oui mais pardon les
moyens mis dans la justice ne seront pas
suffisants nous dépensons toujours deux
fois moins que le reste des endroits
police oui plus de moyens de la justice
est ce que l'état au lieu de s'occuper
de tout ce qu'il ne sait pas faire
notamment dans le domaine économique se
concentre sur la seule chose qu'il est
capable de faire et de faire bien et
qu'il est le seul à pouvoir faire la
police la justice l'armée mission celle
que vous lancez aujourd'hui bien sûr
c'est ça le sujet vous inquiétez pas du
reste occupez vous de l'association div
avait raison sur un point si on dit
qu'on fait son retour à la proximité du
citoyen à l'information du citoyen faut
plus de policiers et donc on a besoin
d'une quinzaine de milliers de policiers
supplémentaires dans notre pays au cours
des cinq prochaines années
dernier élément on a besoin de changer
des lois et si un concept psq police de
sécurité du quotidien c'est qu'il faut
changer des lois
à quoi ça sert de mettre des policiers
qu'ils soient nationaux ou municipaux à
courir derrière des gens qui font du
rodéo en métaux or en moto à la sortie
d'une école
si on lui rend la moto dix minutes qu'un
quart d'heure deux heures après la
question s'est il faut aussi changer des
lois pour les rendre beaucoup plus
simple si vous faites du rodéo en moto
ou que vous circulez avec une voiture
sans permis on vous confisque la voiture
et la moto comme ça vous arrêtez
d'enquiquiner le monde ça me fais plus
de fermeté que vous avez d'ailleurs si
monsieur collomb lorsqu'il présentera un
projet de loi sera capable d'écouter
ceux qui ne sont pas forcément de son
avis toujours vers via ce jour là cette
semaine bien le moment assez fort ce que
c'est écouter l'avis des français c'est
pour ça que je sombre entendu cette
manière un moment assez fort vous étiez
certainement dans l'hémicycle à ce
moment-là ce ténor des questions
d'actualité ce mercredi jean luc
mélenchon a pris la parole celui des
menaces contre christophe castaner
raquette à ministre contre jean luc
mélenchon des menaces venues de l'ultra
droite regardez cette séquence et puis
j'aimerais avoir votre votre commentaire
juste après je crois à exprimer le point
de vue de tous mes collègues sur tous
les bancs lorsque j'adresse à ces
énergumènes le message suivant rien
jamais aucune menace ne fera jamais
céder aucun d'entre nous dans le devoir
de représenter la liberté d'expression
du peuple français
je n'ai l'intention naturellement de ne
passer à aucune forme de polémique
je me permets une suggestion monsieur le
premier ministre
le ridicule qui comptait nous assaillir
a été arrêté le 28 juin
quatre mois plus tard je la prends
j'estime que monsieur castaner et moi
sommes sommes assez mûr pour évaluer les
menaces qui pèsent sur nous tous seuls
et j'aurais apprécié d'en être informés
je crois que vous pourrez me rejoindre
sur ce sujet qu'en la matière il faut
laisser aussi peut-être pas seulement
mais aussi aux forces de l'ordre et à
l'autorité judiciaire qui mène l'enquêté
le soin de déterminer si nous sommes
dans quelque chose qui est caractérisée
et sérieux et le soin de mener son
enquête sans fragiliser
l'enquète qui est en cours vous avez
vous est adressée à la représentation
nationale en indiquant que rien ne
pourrait faire changer d'avis quiconque
ici
et certainement pas les menaces je
voudrais dire au nom du gouvernement que
c'est une superbe même si elle ne me
surprend pas mais c'est une superbe
attitude de la représentation nationale
qui fait honneur à notre démocratie
voilà pour cette séquence jean
christophe lagarde est la raison jean
luc mélenchon lorsqu'il dit qu'il aurait
souhaité être prévenu l'aurait dû être
prévenu
je pense que c'est que l'information a
résolu parvenir je pense que c'est
compliqué on arrête un individu dont on
pense qu'ils préparent un attentat
contre un ministre et contre leaders
politiques ou un élu de la république
les deux services ils doivent enquêter
et savoir s'il n'y a pas plus de gens
qui sont dans un complot qu'il ya une
enquête en cours et une enquête en cours
prévenir au moment de l' enquête en
cours c'est risquer de tuer l'enquète
laval la vraie question à mon avis elle
est pas là
c est ce que le ministre de l'intérieur
dans ce contexte là a pris les
dispositions pour protéger jean luc
mélenchon castaner il est ministre il
est protégé tout le temps enfin c'est ce
qu'on a pris des mesures pour protéger
jean luc mélenchon pendant cette période
d' enquête pour savoir pour
l'interrogation mais aussi bien sûr
puisque juste un point d'interrogation
et si j'avais été en responsabilité
dans ce domaine j'aurais simplement
veiller pendant l' enquête pour savoir
s'il y avait d'autres personnes qui
complotait et qui me situer des nuls
protéger des élus qui étaient visés
parce que les disques on vient l'arrêter
c'est vrai qu'ils ont eu quelques mois
entre guillemets j'espère j'imagine
qu'ils y accèdent enfin des formules et
de fans de critiques contre le ministre
de l'intérieur pourquoi mais ce n'est
pas une critique c'est parce que c'est
une altercation
vous me posez la question est-ce qu'il
fallait le dire à mélenchon je pense que
cette question est légitime de la part
de jean luc mélenchon humainement mais
qu'elle est secondaire en ordre public
et en gestion de l'état la question
c'est est-ce qu'ils étaient protégés
est-ce qu'on n'a pas pris de risques jeu
c'est pas une critique bon et tout à
l'heure je disais si alors là pour
l'occasion le prochain projet de loi est
ce que monsieur collomb sera capable
d'écouter dans le projet de loi qui
vient de passer sur le terrorisme ne l'a
pas été et donc je continue c'est même
seul on peut continuer à vouloir porter
la politique différemment
j'aimerais bien que ce qu'il apportait
différemment il ya six mois la porte
réellement nous écoute pas c'est donc
les pas que nous pardon j'ai entendu
parfois rarement des gens de france
insoumise ou des républicains voir des
gens du parti socialiste dire des choses
qui étaient juste les quand c'est juste
c'est juste mon un chien c'est pas la
peine de se braquer parce que ça vient
pas de vos rangs c'est quand même ce que
disait me semble-t-il emmanuel macron
pendant la campagne présidentielle et
c'est mieux d'appliquer ce qu'on dit
après aussi voilà on va retrouver toute
notre partenaire du figaro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour d'une bière amicalement focaccia
bonjour jean christophe lagarde jeu
mardi prochain le bureau politique des
républicains devraient enfin après de
nombreuses tergiversations exclure les
constructif de son sein est ce que ça va
accélérer la formation du grand parti de
centre-droit progressiste que vous
appelez de vos voeux depuis quelques
jours plusieurs semaines or forte
heureusement c'est pas les républicains
qui vont donner le tempo et liming
auquel nous ont construit une force
politique du centre et de la droite
progressiste qui permet en réalité à
tous les gens qui veulent des attitudes
politiques nouvelles je lis beaucoup
expliquer mais je vais insister encore
une fois de se retrouver dans leurs
valeurs et d'essayer de travailler pour
le pays plutôt que d'attendre la chute
du pouvoir pour le récupérer le
lendemain et est donc d'ici enfin on est
en train d'y réfléchir on discute c'est
pas quelque chose de facile tout
simplement ce qu'est une pluralité de
gens il ya l'ue dit certes là on est un
parti politique structuré organisé le
sol dans cet espace politique
puis il ya les gens dans les élus locaux
parmi les députés parmi les blessés mais
mon père aime également les militants
qui sont non le modèle n'a pas cédé pas
dans ce cadre là pardon et qui sont en
réflexion
y compris d'ailleurs comment on crée une
forme où on constitue une formation
politique aujourd'hui l'élection
présidentielle a montré que les
formations politiques et sont
nécessaires ball organisé le débat mais
que c'est pas fait qu'elles doivent être
profondément modifiée et modernisé non
deuxième chose vous m'interposer sur le
modem oui le modem aujourd'hui est un
parti qui est alliée de la république en
marche qui a eu ses élus grâce à la
république en marché à manuel macron et
qui est dans une situation de dépendance
de la république en marche et donc la
réalité c'est que nous au moment où on
veut construire une force indépendante
on peut pas ça klur là dedans est ce que
ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas des choses
en tout cas le modèle n'a pas sa place
dans ce mouvement que vous souhaitez
dans les partitions de musique dans
l'indépendance il la reprend on verra
mais aujourd'hui il est dépendant et
c'est bien normal d'une majorité à qui
il doit elle avait cru que vous lui avez
tant de larmes ans à qui il doit ses
députés vous trompez pardon c'est
monsieur bayrou qui est voulu aggraver
les voitures mini quand je dis je suis
indépendant c'est pas pour me lier avec
quelqu'un qui n'est pas indépendant est
ce que pour autant ça veut dire qu'avec
un certain nombre
deux parlementaires du modem ou de
militants ou élus locaux du modem on ne
partage rien bien sûr que s'il ya des
choses qu'on partage
nous ne partageons pas cette dépendance
à la majorité actuelle
dernière question très rapidement la
parole des femmes se libère autour des
cas de harcèlement sexuel on apprend ce
matin que c'est l'ancien ministre de
françois mitterrand pierre joxe qui est
accusé d'attouchements par la fille de
l'ancien ministre éric besson qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire pas ça ça ça
m'inspire rien que que du dégoût non
c'est je pense que l'accumulation des
témoignages montrent l'ampleur du
problème dans notre pays ça c'est la
première chose en 20 secondes me suis
donc que la parole de lit se libère
c'est bien donc ça veut dire qu'il est
une bataille à mener d'urgence y compris
d'ailleurs pour allonger les délais de
prescription pour que les victimes qui
sont traumatisés puisse porter plainte
plus tard pour se faire justice
ça veut dire que tout citoyen qui
connaît un crime ou un délit a le devoir
de le signaler
non c'est vous mais celia vous essayez
pas mais c'est dur parce que pardon ça
la vie politique qui vous entourent si
jamais ce que je peux formuler ma
réponse je vous en remercie est ce que à
chaque fois qu'il ya une dénonciation il
ya un coupable
non c'est à dire que y compris sur le
site ce que je crois c'est qu'il est
nécessaire que la justice soit saisie
parce que ça sert à rien des dents c'est
quelqu'un s'il n'est pas puni et ça sert
à rien évidemment de dénoncer quelqu'un
s'il est ce sera la premier league est
innocent et pour ça il faut que la
justice et la justice ait pas de la
justice médiatique et pas de la justice
populaire et la justice de la république
c'est le mot de la fin
merci jean christophe lagarde merci à
tous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
[Musique]